in early january a group of businesses
from the healthcare sector announced
they were working together to create
digital vaccine id cards that
verify covet 19 vaccination status
these cards would be digital stored on
smartphones and other digital devices
and in the future may be required to
gain entry into restaurants
schools and airplanes the goal is
to make sure that they're not faked and
so right now
the current system is just getting these
white cards
and that could easily be faked and so
these are verifiable they're
downloadable they're secure
they're encrypted and the goal is that
if you wanted to go somewhere like a
concert or a restaurant
that was only letting people in if they
had vaccines you could just pull it up
on your phone
they could scan it and know that you're
vaccinated then let you into the menu
the coalition includes big name
companies like evernorth
oracle and mitre despite their
differences these companies say they've
come together with the goal of ending
the pandemic as soon as possible
the thing that i think is really
interesting is that a lot of these
companies are competitors actually
so like cerner and epic are competitors
in the electronic medical records field
but they came together to try to make
this system interoperable
which basically means they want it to be
usable no matter
what company you use for your medical
records no matter if
you use an iphone or android no matter
if you don't use a phone at all
in the us there's a really big digital
divide and so they're making it
accessible for
people who don't necessarily have
smartphones for people who don't have
phones or smartphones have qr codes
printed on papers that can also be
scannable and confirm vaccination
status there are also other issues other
than making sure the cards are
accessible
another really big challenge is having
people actually adopt the technology
so convincing people to use it and the
way that's probably going to work is
that i'm assuming that people
are going to mostly be using it out of
necessity like if you want to go travel
somewhere and the airline says well
you know you can't board unless you have
one of these ids
then you're going to download it and get
with the program
and then also there's some ethical
dilemmas can employers
make employees get vaccinated to go back
to work can schools
mandate that kids get vaccinated if we
don't know how well the vaccine works
against children at this point
there's a lot of ethical hurdles and i
think a lot of those are going to become
more and more apparent
as this begins to roll out it's unclear
exactly how far they are
the people that i spoke to said that it
could be within a few months
definitely by the end of this year they
plan to have these cards accessible
but i would say start looking for in the
next few months